er wollte lammkoteletts in einem bistro
grill lassen und verlor am ende sein
bein und zwar weil ein koch ihm mit
einem döner messer sein bein abgetrennt
hat rückblick es ist der zehnte
september 2018 im al madina bistro der
damals 17-jährige cello kommt mit
freunden in den laden will dort
lammkoteletts grillen laut anklage tat
er das öfter mit dem einverständnis des
bistro betreibers doch der ist an diesem
tag nicht da nur der neue koch erkennt
die vereinbarung nicht und verweigert
den wunsch und dann eskaliert der streit
koch und kunde jagen sich mit
glasflaschen glasflaschen und stühlen
durch das bistro und auf der straße
passiert dann die bluttat der kopf
durchtrennt will ins bein mit einem
döner messe heute hat das landgericht in
leipzig sein urteil gesprochen
das leipziger landgericht hat heute
einen 29 jährigen algerier zu
dreieinhalb jahren gefängnis verurteilt
dem mann war vorgeworfen worden nach
einem streit in einem bistro in der
leipziger innenstadt 2018 einem gast das
klinge beiden mit einem döner messe
abgehakt zu haben
das amtsgericht hatte diesen mann noch
letztes jahr zu zwei jahren auf
bewährung verurteilt viel zu wenig für
staatsanwaltschaft und nebenklage
das landgericht folgte heute dem der
argumentation der staatsanwaltschaft
dass ein ob überhaupt das bein nicht
mehr bewährungs fähig ist strafmildernd
die strafe hätte viel höher ausfallen
könnte strafmildernd kommen dem koch
zugute dass er sich entschuldigt hat und
die tat schwer bereut